sunscreen sticks can be really useful
but how are you meant to use them
I did some experiments to find out and
I was pretty shocked by the results
I'm Michelle of lab muffin
beauty science chemistry
PhD cosmetic chemist and sunscreen connoisseur
I talk a lot about sunscreens but I haven't
talked that much about sunscreen sticks
these have been getting more popular and
if you've used any of the newer ones you'll
know there's been a lot of progress since the
thick bright zinc sticks from school carnivals
there are a lot of upsides to sticks
first off sunscreen sticks are really convenient
you don't need to wash your
hands if you want to reapply
you don't end up with
sunscreen all over your hands
you just take off the cap
and glide it onto your skin
they're solid so there's no
chance of squirting it everywhere
and you don't need to worry
about liquid limits for planes
they're also really good to use on wriggly kids
sticks can also be great for reapplying sunscreen
over makeup without smearing it around too much if
you find one that glides on smoothly and these
days a lot of them do glide on really smoothly
they can also help with eye sting
sticks are a lot waxier than lotions
so if you have issues with sunscreen
running into your eyes and stinging
then sticks might help you out and you
can use it just around your eye area
but sticks also have a lot of downsides
the most obvious one is it is a lot
harder to measure out how much you
need to use or work out how much you've applied
you need two milligrams of sunscreen
per square centimeter of skin to get
the labelled protection which converts to a
bit under a quarter teaspoon for most faces
but you can't really dig out a quarter spoon of a
sunscreen stick without losing a lot
of the advantages of having a stick
so I decided to test how much
of each stick I was applying
I tried tocobo abib and
benton sticks for this video
these are three of the nicest
sunscreen sticks I've tried so far
note that these are all Korean sunscreens
they aren't approved as sunscreens in a
lot of countries including Australia and the US
SPF tests are done by weight so I also
did this by weight to be more accurate
a while ago I measured my
face and it turns out I need
0.76 grams of sunscreen to get the labelled SPF
for every stick I zeroed the
scales then I applied what I
thought was a very generous layer
more than I would normally apply
the tocobo and abib sticks are chemical sunscreens
so as you'd expect there wasn't any white cast
benton's stick is mineral based
on titanium dioxide and it is
pretty non-whitening for a mineral sunscreen
after that very generous layer I
re-weighed the sticks and it turns
out I only applied about one third of
the amount I needed for every stick
for an SPF 50 sunscreen this would
translate to very roughly SPF 19
I also checked how much time I spent
with each stick actually touching my
skin so you can get an idea of what
I considered a "generous application"
these are about 20% shorter than the total
application time including the
gaps when the stick left my skin
the full procedures I used
are linked in the description
out of these I applied the
most of the Benton stick
and I think it's because it is a bit grippier
it didn't glide as smoothly over my
skin so it took longer before it felt
like I'd covered my skin thoroughly
the tocobo was in the middle and the abib
ended up with the least amount applied
all three of these still felt
really nice on my skin at this stage
tocobo gives more of a matte silky
finish while the abib feels a bit
more emollient there was only a
little white cast with the Benton
onto layer 2 I went in again for
what seemed to me to be another
really generous layer and again
I applied less than I expected
this got me up to an average of SPF
31 which is good but I can usually
apply the full amount of a lotion
sunscreen without this much effort
by this time I'd spent one and a half to two and a
half minutes with each sunscreen stick on my skin
after layer 2 the tacopo had caught up
with the Benton and I think that's because
the Benton doesn't grip onto itself
as well as it gripped onto my skin
the textures were still passable
but starting to get slidey
I don't think makeup would stay
put too well on top of this but
you might have better luck if
your skin is drier than mine
onto layer 3 and this time
I got up to average SPF 42
tocobo won but all three were pretty messy
by this point they were greasy and didn't set
the two chemical sunscreens were still
impressively transparent but I could
scrape a white layer of the Benton off my skin
I didn't even think I could
apply any more after this it
was getting to the point where my skin
was applying sunscreen back to the stick
by this stage I'd spent an average
of three minutes with each stick
on my skin which is about four
minutes total application time
for comparison it takes me about a minute to
apply the full amount of a lotion on my skin
I've seen a recommendation from the AAD
for applying four swipes of a sunscreen
stick to get full protection so I also tried to
count how many swipes of each sunscreen I used
I picked four spots on my face and counted how
many times each stick passed over each spot
on average it was 9 21 and 34
swipes for one two and three layers
four swipes of these SPF 50 sticks
would definitely not be enough
number of swipes and passes also
just seems to to be a bad guideline
you can see how I ended up applying a lot
more swipes on my left cheek than my right
even in the AAD demonstration you
can see her passes aren't overlapping
I also tested applying the
sunscreen sticks on my arms
I needed less about 20 swipes of the
tocobo sunscreen to get full coverage
I think it's because my arm hair
grabbed onto more sunscreen per
swipe and I could press harder and
the skin is just a lot more uniform
there's a lot less curves to move around
it was pretty clear 10 swipes wouldn't be
enough and four would definitely not be enough
also if you're wondering you can't
see if you've applied enough sunscreen
with a UV camera everything over
four swipes looks around the same
I'm guessing this could potentially be the
origin of this "four swipes" recommendation
this also highlights that
UV cameras are a really bad
way of estimating SPF which I've talked
about before in my video on SPF testing
so based on this I really don't think
a sunscreen stick is a great choice as
your main form of sun protection
if you're getting a lot of sun
you're probably applying a lot less
sunscreen than you think you are
I was certainly surprised
and I think some of this is down
to how sticks are formulated
sunscreen lotions are usually about
half water at least and sometimes
they also have volatile solvents
like alcohol and cyclopentasiloxane
after applying the right amount the sunscreen
dries down and these evaporate off your skin
there aren't many volatile ingredients
in sticks everything sits on top of your
skin plus the texture is thicker the oils don't
sink in as much and you can feel it a lot more
if you apply the right amount
of a stick you end up with a
much thicker layer on your skin than with a lotion
it also takes a lot longer
to apply the full amount
I also found that it was easier
for me to miss spots with a stick
I checked what the coverage was
like after my first generous layer
which I thought was enough for the
chemical sunscreens using a UV camera
you can't really see mineral
sunscreens very clearly through UV
I can apply a lotion on my face
without looking and only miss a
couple of spots but even while staring
at myself well I missed a whole bunch
of spots that I've never missed
before like the middle of my nose
I also missed some spots that I miss quite often
like under my eyebrows and next to my nostrils
I don't know what that spot's called
the nose crevice?
this was pretty easy to fix you just have to
rub the stick in but again you
lose a bit of that convenience
and if you don't have a UV
camera you can't really see
which bits need rubbing you have to rub all over
you can sort of see a bit from the shine but
that white cast from the mineral
stick could actually be handy here
I think the shape of the stick can make a
difference when it comes to missing spots
sticks do come in a lot of different shapes
and I'm not really sure which one I preferred
the curve of the abib stick kind of feels like
a face massage and the wide shape covers the
cheeks and your forehead really quickly but
it is a bit fiddly to get into awkward areas
I think that's also why I needed less
wipes on my arm compared to my face
one swipe covers more surface area
on a flat surface than a curved one
so to sum up for sunscreen sticks it's great if
you need a small top up especially over makeup
if you want to avoid getting
sunscreen on your hands
to avoid eye sting
and when other options don't work like if
you've got really wriggly or fussy kids
but I wouldn't recommend them on your own if you
need a lot of sun protection - I
would recommend a lotion instead
I hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
some of the different types of sunscreens
links to all of the products in
the description also check out
my skincare science playlist
if you want more deep dives